So now that we understand
how services work,
let's review how Android
determines your app's priority.
App priority is divided
into three general buckets.
Critical, high, and low.
Within each bucket the apps
are prioritized in a queue,
with the app that's been
at the lowest priority for the longest
the first to be executed.
Critical apps are those
that are active.
They're in the foreground,
interacting with users.
That includes activities
in the foreground,
and apps running
foreground services.
High priority apps,
include any visible activities,
and any application
with a running service.
While less impactful than
killing a foreground app,
destroying visible activities
or cancelling services running tasks
like background updates,
is still going to be noticeable to users.
So, the system will only kill them
in an extreme resource crunch.
Apps in the background though,
they're the red shirted ensigns
of the app priority landing party.
Any background app
will be killed as needed
in a last seen, first killed order,
in order to help support
the higher priority apps.
I like to think of this
as the three laws
of Android resource management.
Law one, Android will keep
all apps that interact with the user
running smoothly.
Android will keep all apps
with visible activities
or running services running,
unless doing so violates the first law.
And third, Android will keep all apps
in the background running,
unless this violates
the first or second laws.
So with all of that in mind,
consider these four apps.
What do you think
is the priority order
of each of these apps,
according to the system?